Amy robach
you may have heard of her because she
was caught on a hidden mic discussing
how she wanted to pursue the Jeffrey
Epstein story at ABC and the producers
and the executives shut her down and she
knew that Jeffrey Epstein was a real
story
when she knew that this involved a lot
of corruption she wanted to run the
story and the higher-ups at the network
said nope don't talk about that so it
adds another layer to this where I think
huh it's so so weird how people who
transgress the
powerful liberal Elites people people
who contradict them or who get on the
wrong side of them they end up in a sex
scandal and their career goes away and
then they bury them not all that long
after they raise these problems really
weird not obviously what they did is
terribly wrong and they should repent of
it and go to confession and try to make
up with their spouses and try to keep
their families together
there's a lot more to this story though